thank you
hello ladies and gentlemen I'm not kemi
bad knock obviously
I'm I'm
um Liam Halligan I'm from uh GB news I'm
also a long-standing columnist in the
Sunday Telegraph and I've been asked by
Cami to
host a q a session with her so you can
get to know her a little bit better
we've only got 20 minutes uh I think I
can see the clock somewhere so let's
kick off
Cami I think the first time you took the
stage at the Conservative Party
Conference was in
2017. you were the Walmart pact for the
prime minister no less Theresa May in
Manchester
um certain things happened in that
speech like letters falling off the set
and so on which meant perhaps you didn't
get the headlines you deserved but you'd
already made a mark in politics you came
into the house uh in 2017 you give given
your maiden speech on brexit it was a
very fast elevation to censor stage of
the conservative party but he's been in
politics for quite a long time hadn't
you I think you first stood against
Tessa Zhao in 2010 yes
so what's the question so the question
[Applause]
so I guess the question was how did it
feel after quite a long time
to stand up and address conference on
that day um
yeah
it's wonderful because you know I tell
people the conservative party is my
family uh you know and even in that
speech I talked about how I married my
Deputy chairman but giving speeches is
that is is terrifying which is why I'm
doing it in conversation
um this evening because despite the fact
that people seem to like it when I say
stuff I worry about the things that can
go wrong and I find having a
conversation an easier way of explaining
some of the things that are important
about conservative philosophy than just
talking
um in the speech the conservative party
have known about you and your talents
for for a long time despite the
relatively short time you've been in
Parliament and I think the whole country
really got to know you during the
conservative leadership contest when you
saw that there was going to be a
leadership contest how long did it take
you kemi to decide to stand
um about 24 hours and it was it's very
hard to describe the mindset that I was
in at the time I had resigned after
agonizing over resigning I didn't want
to resign and I resigned with with my
friends uh who are both sort of friends
personally as well as philosophically
and there were so many things which I
felt I had not been able to say because
I'd been on payroll for a very long time
I've been a minister a party Vice
chairman and I thought now I'm a back
venture now I can see exactly what I um
what I think but uh how what will make
people listen and what is it that I
think our party needs to do and quite a
few people also encouraged me to stand
so it wasn't just the fit of megalomania
I did have a lot of people encouraging
me but it was difficult because when
you're starting to be leader of a party
and in in this case to be prime minister
of a country it's a very serious
decision there's going to be a huge
impact on your family and you can't also
help feeling overwhelmed by impulse this
interim so on the one hand you know
someone who is fairly ideological like
me you know I I know what I think and
know this things have to be done in a
certain way this absolutely has to be
done and then you think oh my God being
prime minister of a country imposter
syndrome sort of um overwhelms you so
you're going through quite a lot of
turmoil of emotions but I'm really glad
I stood in the contest I think that I
said a lot of the things that um uh the
party wanted to hear but um and I don't
think I would have been a secretary of
state without it it was nice to be able
to show uh Liz now the Prime Minister
that I could do more than what I had
been doing and I'm really grateful for
the opportunity that she's given me and
I have to say to quote Bruce Forsyth
ladies and gentlemen didn't she do well
laughs
tell us a little bit about your early
life you were born in the UK
um but then you very quickly went back
to your to your family in Nigeria you it
wasn't just a passing thing you spent
your childhood in Nigeria you had a
properly African childhood how did that
impact your political philosophy your
ideology how did that impact your drive
to get to the top of British politics
um significantly almost everything that
I think is formed from having grown up
in a developing country and I mean my
political philosophy is probably Roger
scrutin plus Thomas owl for those of you
who know um who those authors are I'm a
child of both of those two men that
that's what I think about the world and
growing up in Nigeria meant that I had
uh experiences that can't be taken away
by by poor arguments so I I was born
into a relatively wealthy family but we
lost all our money so people are often
confused when I talk about growing up in
poverty but I experienced both
um which means I'm terrified of
inflation because inflation wiped away
everything that my and you understand
Financial insecurity exactly in a way a
lot of people in our political class and
our media class don't precisely so it's
informed a lot of my economic views my
views are on authoritarianism I grew up
under a military government so loving
freedom and being free to be able to do
things and think for yourself is really
really important I mean when I was at
school there was one particular military
government where his teachers were late
they got flogged on the streets before
they got to the school not just the not
just the students it was it was such a
contrast to moving to a place where
freedom is is really important but also
even things like free trade and learning
that you can't Buck the market you know
the iron laws of supply and demand you
would get um you know export controls
and capital controls and all of a sudden
the currency would go Haywire so a lot
of very strong views on on economics but
also even and I know that it's been
covered a bit some of the comments I've
made in earlier um uh panels about
immigration my views on immigration were
formed by my father who was a GP not
being able to hire medical staff because
all of them have come here or gone to
the UK um to the U.S and we need to be
very careful about what we're doing to
other countries in the way that we we
think about migration migration is um
I I don't think we should talk about
immigration as if people are economic
units they are more than that and when
people come to a country there is
um there is a contract that's being made
about joining an existing society and we
need to think about it more broadly
rather than people come here to work and
make us wealthier or look after our or
elderly there's something more that's
going on and I'm hoping that we can have
a much better conversation about
immigration than the one we've been
having in this country and I speak as a
first generation immigrant so I know
that there are a lot of things that's
probably easier for me to say than
others and I think that I should use my
voice to have a civilized conversation
about what kind of country we want to be
and just briefly I've been to Nigeria
several times West Africa in general
Nigeria is an incredibly Dynamic
entrepreneurial place it's full of very
very very talented people but it's also
a place which with all respects and I
say this with a lot of respect for
Nigeria and West Africa in general
it needs leadership and I guess that's
another lesson that you learn from
living in Nigeria yes good good
leadership a respect for institutions or
respect for the rule of law all of the
things that make the the United Kingdom
great and we know that our country is
great because every day we see you know
thousands of people trying to get here
and it's one of the reasons why I'm so
frustrated with the narrative about how
terrible the UK is and how everything we
do is wrong and it's it's quite striking
to hear people talk about their own
country in this way many people who you
would consider part of the
establishments um
uh thank you um and Emily talking down
their country because it has it has an
impact it even has an impact on things
like my my new role in trade if you are
telling the rest of the world that your
country is you know is terrible and
racist what do you think happens when
your trade secretary goes to uh
developing country to to ask for things
it means that they suddenly will view
you with suspicion there there's so many
knock-on effects of this type of talk
that people don't um that people don't
realize it is it is very indulgent and
um it frustrates me because when I try
and talk about these things I end up
being characterized as a culture Warrior
these things are not trivial they're
very very serious and um you need to get
a little bit more serious about that our
economic problems and our cultural
problems um as we think that they are
quite interlinked and separating the two
um isn't necessarily helpful in terms of
finding a way forward
now as I've got to know you over recent
years I've come to understand that you
really are a politician with a
hinterland you're you're a trained
engineer you you really know your way
around coding and computers and so on
you you work very closely uh in terms of
your politics with Hamish uh bad knock
who himself stood as a conservative
councilor it was a conservative
counselor in Merton in South London
you've got three lovely young children
politics is really really important to
you and indeed to Hamish but it's not
everything is it you do have a life
outside of politics not anymore
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but you did do things before you came
into Parliament how important is that
that you had a career in your own right
you weren't just a you know you didn't
just go from a PPE course to become a
spad and then into politics no I
actually think a lot of the things I did
um just before and during University
helped shape me I mean anyone who
watched the leadership class things
would have heard me talk about
McDonald's a thousand times yeah that
was my first job and it had a profound
were you any good no I actually um I
wasn't because I never got the Stars
it was not my um it was not where my
core skill set was it the fry station
didn't perform or the show is bad in the
kitchen
and but I was okay with the money it's a
great cook yeah yeah yes and and so so
jobs like that having grown up as I said
in um in a family that was worthy and
didn't have to do things like that that
really shaped me and I had to do lots of
10 jobs I had an apprenticeship before I
went into went to University so all of
those things influenced me and then
after my degree going into into software
Consulting and working in Banks it just
sort of gave me a little bit of a
broader sort of job history before
politics but you made your way into
politics onto the candidates list many
people here and conservatives across the
country will be very grateful for that I
think somebody called Francis Moore
played a role
yes so Francis Ward
um actually it was my trade Minister I
don't know if I thought you were going
to ask me questions about trade um
earlier we're coming too okay fine um so
actually my I was I met
um a man at a party Christmas party uh
for the young conservatives whose name's
Connor Burns and he said I think you're
amazing you should meet the party
chairman who was Francis Maude and
Francis Moore said oh you should really
think about becoming an MP and it's
really funny because Connor Burns is of
course now my junior minister in um
having him uh working with me because I
actually wouldn't be here if we hadn't
had that conversation I went into that
room I didn't know anybody and it's one
of the examples of how our party is so
welcoming to so many people and just
having somebody say hello who are you
and have a conversation and then
17 years later here I am
you do now have a big Hefty role in
cabinet the the trade portfolio I think
you're in the states last week
um trying to drum up business for the UK
back banging the drum as you say
tell us about what you want to try and
Achieve during your time as trade
secretary Kevin so the Prime Minister
has given me a mandate uh you all know
that we have a growth plan and the
department for international trade is is
integral to that plan and I'm going to
do everything to help her deliver on her
um on her agenda I fully support the
Prime Minister 100 I think that we do
I do um I think
um and uh I think we do need to make
sure that the conservative message
around the economy is one that doesn't
get lost
um in a lot of the media uh in a lot of
the media storms that we see so yes
trade is going to be very important
um I am trying to shift the uh the
Overton window of trade as we see it
Beyond trade deals so everyone thinks
the department of international trade
does trade deals so trade deals are
great but they're not the only thing
trade deals are like the motorway it's
fantastic you get them built but if the
cars aren't going back and forth then
you might as well not have built them
and but going back and forth is exports
um and Investments you know we have a
new investment Minister Dominic Johnson
who I'm delighted uh to hear has joined
uh the team with James Dodge Ridge
um and Connor Burns and I think that um
I think we're going to be a fantastic
team but we're going to be working not
just on signing deals but making sure
the people are actually using them
making sure that our businesses um are
able to get their um their goods out
there that people want to invest in the
UK and what I learned in the US is that
people really love our country they
think that this is a safe place for them
to invest their money the US is the
single biggest investor in the UK
without a trade deal 459 billion and 17
of our trade absolutely one and a half
million Brits work in um due to an
American company every day so trade
deals yes they are they are essential
but actually making sure that we stop
people from creating new regulations
outside the trade deal that will harm
our businesses it requires quite a lot
of day-to-day dialogue it's not um it's
not exciting a lot of it's very
technical
um you know dealing with a WTO but it
makes a difference to Everyday People it
helps businesses grow and it means that
we continue to develop our reputation in
the world and so that's what I'm going
to be doing as trade sectors even before
brexit of course the uh the majority of
our trade was outside of the EU we were
unique in the EU in that sense which is
one reason why the Customs Union in the
eyes of many I know you uh wasn't
suitable for of the UK but of course
Europe remains doesn't it a major
trading partner so I guess you'll be
spending quite a lot of your time
talking to EU members as well yes that's
right and just because we're not um
within the single Market doesn't mean
that there aren't other things that we
can do so for instance I know that we
have an investment partnership that
we're working with uh Norway on for
example there are loads of individual
Partnerships that we can have and even
though the US is not doing any trade
deals uh at the moment we are able to
have a memorandum of understanding uh
with States so we can do many trade
deals with the with the um with the 50
states of of the us and one of the
things that I'm more worried about is
that the entire world is becoming more
protectionist whether it's the US
focusing on by America or other
countries uh subsidizing their markets
you look at what China is doing we need
a Level Playing Field in order to have
good free trade and trade is not just um
the primary purpose of trade in my view
is as a tool for Prosperity but it's not
not just for prosperity it's also a tool
for security when you look at Food
security or even energy security our
trade policy is going to have an impact
on how we live our lives far into the
future what are the critical minerals
that we need to get to ensure that we
can build electric vehicles for example
are we going to get locked out of those
regions because China and Russia got
there first we mustn't allow anything
like that to happen and it's going to
require a very front footed trade team
and the trade policy from the UK that is
global and outward looking but making
sure that we still stay in a close
relationship with our existing allies
now your member for staff modern of
course beautiful North Essex Market Town
distinguished
which is why that's why I asked them to
do this
former former members for saffron modern
of Court have included Deputy common
speaker Alan Hazelhurst and indeed
nobody less than R.A Butler who is uh
whose grave is next to the beautiful
Saffron Walden St Mary's Church
um just give us a little bit of your
sense of how important education has
been to you and getting you where you
are now and your passion for education
at
it's a cliche to say so I would never I
would not be here without the very good
education which I had had um supported
uh of course by my parents and their
philosophy that it was the most
important thing and when you see just
how many people around the world
struggle to get a good education you
don't take it for granted here but it's
also the reason why I'm of the view that
we need to have rigorous standards
um across the board in all our schools
and also give teachers the tools that
they need to make sure that we can
educate our children so that they're the
brightest and the best
foreign
question is this identity politics it is
something that you speak out on quite
often though I know very strongly you
don't want to be identified with that
your your talents and and interests Go
Far Far broader but how have we got to
this point how have we got to the point
where there's contention over
definitions of of what a woman is and so
on and it's I think a lot of things have
happened at the uh at the same time but
what I would say is that many of the
people not all of them but many of the
people who have the views that are odds
are at odds with the way we
conservatives see the world is that they
that they are trying to fill a void and
I remember being at an event where I um
I had spoken and I met these very young
uh ladies who people would call work
it's not a word that I actually use I I
think it trivializes what is going on so
if you see me being quoted as as using
the word maybe that I probably didn't
fake news yeah yeah except for now when
I just used it but
but um but yeah we had a long
conversation and um after after the the
argument I could tell that they weren't
really solid in what they were thinking
and I asked them well why do you think
this and one of them said because I I
knew I want to feel like I'm a part of
something important and we mustn't
forget that at the heart of this is
something a lot of people are trying to
find their way around the world whether
it's replacing religion or family or a
sense of belonging and that's something
which as conservatives we completely
understand the problem is that on top of
this there is a an activist class of
people and we know who they are we see
them outside chanting at protests and
they're they're at every protest with
the Socialist work and party banner and
they exploit actually the issues that a
lot of people have to attack what I
would call our
um conservative and liberal values it's
not only conservatives who are under
attack in fact if you look at many of
the issues um the gender critical women
have faced it's mainly people on the lab
so I think that there's something
missing in but the reason why it's got
to this stage is because we have lost
the art of political arguments ourselves
so I don't think that as conservatives
we should point fingers all the time
sometimes we need to look inwards and
look at what we are doing wrong and one
of those things is actually not making
the argument enough sometimes conceding
where we shouldn't concede or worried
that people might think that we're big
Earths or one food or the other and not
say the right thing it's absolutely
important to be true to our convictions
and make the argument in a civilized
manner as possible and also actually
force people to say what they mean
thank you we need to we need to we need
to be more precise in our language as
well a lot of the difficult courageous
more courageous more precise get people
to say what they mean quite often we're
having two totally different
conversations
leave Twitter you know it's just a it's
just a bad place uh you know I call it I
call it the devil's message board but
you know it feeds a lot of this
um and also uh you know and I do
consider myself
um on the liberal parts of the of the
conservative Wing but I think sometimes
people don't understand our views of
liberalism and Liberty and they think
that it's the freedom to do bad things
and we must make sure that when we're
talking about Freedom it's not the
freedom to do bad things it's the
freedom to live your life as you choose
while respecting the Dignity of others
and um and always being cognizant of
those who have a different point of view
and I think if we do that then we'll get
to a better place final quick
final question Secretary of State
because we are almost out of time I know
from conversations with you and in
indeed with the Prime Minister and
Chancellor I've over many years that
you share with those two a lot of the
same values about the economy about how
we get growth going the importance of
growing the cake rather than arguing
always about an existing cake I think
it's fair to say recent days have shown
the difficulties of getting that message
across sometimes so how can you the
whole cabinet the whole party when
um activists go out knocking on doors
and so on how can they bring the country
with them when it took in terms of
putting forward this growth plan and
making it stick
as a party we need to get behind the
Prime Minister because if we don't do
that then none of that we need unity and
we need to we need to be able to have
dissent in um you know in a grown-up
fashion I think that when other people
have uh problems with policy I think
there's a way of communicating it and
not necessarily rushing to the first TV
studio to let everybody know how how
angry you are
um even and some other people who've
done this are my friends but it's not
helpful for the whole party so the party
needs to come together and but what we
also uh need to remember who our real
opponents are and that's the labor party
and uh we are not here to fight
ourselves so if we make if we make sure
that we we make our arguments very
clearly
um and the Prime Minister did say
yesterday that um we didn't uh you know
leave the ground work for for it so we
need to communicate better and that's
something that I take as a personal
responsibility explaining what our
party's policies are and doing so in a
way that resonates with the with the
general public but the fact is that we
have not been growing in this country we
have a high GDP but we have a low GDP
per capita Americas is 17 uh more than
ours for example so we do need to do
something about growth and one of the
things that worries me is that there's
so many people out there who are willing
us to fail that we can end up just
losing um the arguments and losing the
country if we aren't sort of more
courageous about explaining why what
we're doing is is right it's also yes
explanation is key but it's also it's
more it is morally right to go for
growth because if people don't have any
growth they don't have any homes they
will become capitalists they won't
become homeowners we need to be able to
create something for our future and
that's why growth is important it is not
an end in itself it's a means to a
better quality of life for everybody and
that's what we're fighting for
well
well
Kenny bade knock MP4 Saffron Walden
didn't I mention Saffron Walden
Secretary of State for trade
um
I've really enjoyed talking to you today
thanks to you for asking me thanks to GB
news for giving me time off in a very
busy day ladies and gentlemen Cami
bednock